freunde das ist der krasseste shader den
ich einfach je installiert hatte
hallo ich in meine lieben villiger
wallis ja das ist jetzt meine neue
begrüßung und herzlich willkommen zu
einem jahr top 5 schrieb shader in
minecraft du mir wird unter die letzten
beiden top fünf videos über meine top 5
tex mex und die top-5 mods ist immer
noch meine meinung also wenn ihr sagt
nur ich kennen trailer der noch viel
viel krank also da die ich kenne hier in
lodz der ist noch viel viel geiler dann
ist es eure meinung ist nur meine
meinung euch zu zeigen was ich feiere
und was mir gefällt und das sind einfach
die top-5 chris taylor von denen man
angst haben sollte die einfach unendlich
krasse dinge machen also es kommt vor
allem die nummer eins ich würde auf
jeden fall bis zur nummer eins abwarten
der ist und zu nummer als nummer zwei
die sind so krass geil oder krass krank
und ich würde einfach sagen ich zeige
euch mal den fünften platz bei mir
das ist nämlich der einzige shader der
schon integriert ist das ist ein super
secret setting hat mich benutzer als
texture pack good morning kraft das ist
mit eines der besten texture pack ich
finde und ihr seht schon das ist alles
so krass umrandet man sieht nahe
zunächst ist gerade tag statt einmal
zeigen wie es bei nacht aus sieht man ja
times 20.000 so sieht das ganz mein
nachbar aus also man sieht halt quasi
eigentlich einfach nur weniger mal
wieder times hätten nur damit ihr seht
wie es bei sonnenaufgang aussieht so
sieht das ganze hier aus es ist total
krank also sieht echt wirklich ich weiß
nicht wie man das beschreiben soll da
hinten geht die sonne auf das sieht man
allerdings nicht so gut so sieht es ganz
bei tag aus und dass es sehr sehr anders
und ich glaube sehr gewöhnungsbedürftig
also ich habe täglich läuft die ganze
zeit immer vereins modus rum weil wenn
ich das so machen dann ist es der maus
cursor damit ist ein bisschen komisch so
sieht mein skin aus ich schon krank und
das ist bei mir der fünfte platz wo
freunde kommen wir zum vierten platz und
zwar ist das der
sonic etwa unbelievable shader version
10.1 preview 3
ein desaster namen habe ich dann
auswendig gelernt ihr findet die
download links und die webseiten zu den
entscheidern in der beschreibung sowie
das auch bei den text apax und bei den
mods der fall war und ihr seht schon
dass es sehr sehr krank ich gebe hier
ins wasser und die sich die wellen
kommen durch mich durch alles mögliche
also sehr sehr detailreich nur die sache
ist halt das ganze ist ein wenig na ja
also ich weiß nicht ein bisschen
schlimme richter ihr seht schon mal ein
skin wackelt hier ein bisschen auch wenn
wir mal hoch fliegen sieht das ganze so
aus als hätte man irgendeine pille
geschluckt ich weiß ich hab noch nie
drogen genommen und ich muss auch jetzt
endlich mal gucken dass ich diesen blog
hier treffe weil das halt so crazy
aussicht ich mein ich meine gucken guckt
euch das mal an das ist doch nicht mehr
normal
das kann auch nicht sein dass es dass
sie so krank aus es sind so komische
farben und auch bei nacht zeige ich euch
das ganze mal so sieht das ganze mich
bei nacht aus sieht man rein gar nichts
mehr und das krasse ist wenn ich jetzt
beispielsweise malawi wo platziere sieht
es schon so aus als ob irgendwie
vielleicht nicht im wasser luca aber
dieses wasser sieht doch so mega grün
aus vier mach ich das mal das ist so
krass hell erleuchtet also das ist so
krank und diese diese bewegung ist
einfach viel zu krass also ist eine
preview bisher sondern so eine
testversion so eine testversion von dem
leopard in der beschreibung und es ist
auf jeden fall richtig krank aber wenn
ihr denkt dass das schon ein krasser
shader ist dann müsst ihr auf jeden fall
noch den ersten platz abwarten
also das ist auf jeden fall schon mal
ein vierter platz und er ist auf jeden
fall erinnert mich ein bisschen an
irgendeinen weil sie nicht an den
drogentrip oder sofas kommen wir zum
dritten schell denkt jetzt erstmal so
jung lukas ein ganz normaler blog ist
doch gar nix da hab ich gesagt dass
alles eine schwarze konto hat ihr gutes
habe ich also wirklich alles hat hier
eine schwarze konturen sondern mich
sehen ich habe auch eine schwarze kontur
außerdem wie die blöcke die ist
mittlerweile so ich das ganze ganz
annehmbar aus
aber wenn ich da wieder hier in gucke
seht ihr alle sich schwarz umrandet und
das sieht schon sehr sehr krasser so ein
bisschen die insm komik wenn man dazu
jetzt eventuell noch diesen schwarz-weiß
super secret setting nehmen würde ich
möchte sich austesten weil ich da wieder
zehn jahre diese super secret settings
zurückstellen muss weil es noch keinen
deaktivieren button klickt man sich so
lange durch klicken muss man wieder beim
normalen modus könnt ihr das einfach mal
austesten dann sieht das ganze glaube
ich guck mal das skelett alter dann
sieht das ganze aus wie im song comic
wir fliegen einfach zum skelette eben
rüber
roskilde berlin du bist aber kein
billiger partie war man village apathie
spawn kommen können machen wo sind die
denn da hamma die diesmal an wille
giabbani da ich ja die und editor
komisch aus sieben texture pack
naja gut also sieht das ganze auf jeden
fall mit diesem schild aus den namen
weiß ich gerade nicht
das ist auf jeden fall ein platz nummer
drei er findet die ganzen downloads dazu
in der beschreibung und mit dem keller
läuft nicht ganz so flüssig aber es ist
ein sehr krasser fehler und er sieht als
es hat irgendwie was finde ich es hat
was wenn das ganze so eine schwarze
konto hat aber ich könnte damit auch
nicht dauerhaft spielen aber das ist auf
jeden fall mal platz nummer drei freunde
kommen wir zum platz nummer zwei ihr
seht schon da hinten bewegt sich so ein
bisschen was im oberen rechten rand des
bildschirms hab ich ja ihr seht schon
das bewegt sich alles ein bisschen und
ja also das ist der spd ist der glaube
ich und zwar gibt es davon zwei
varianten einmal den new world leisure
and space und einmal screen rich and
space oder so das hier ist glaube ich
worldwide and space und auf dem
platzes screen regions pace ich weiß gar
nicht ob ich das genau richtig
aussprechen
jedenfalls ist hier halt der fall egal
wo man hinguckt rechts bewegt sich zum
beispiel die wand gerade dahin bewegt
sich gerade auch alles sieht sehr krass
aus links bewegt sich ja auch alles und
das ist nicht davon beeinflusst wo ich
hingucke also auch wenn ich was den kopf
bewegt sich das da links das
unterscheidet sich vom ersten platz
und zwar dass ihr der erste platz bei
dem das ganze quasi sich dementsprechend
bewegt wo ich hingucke also ihr seht
schon freunde das ist der krasseste
shader die nicht einfach je installiert
hatte
ich kann hier selber bestimmen wo sich
die landschaft quasi hin dreht also ich
kann sagen ok kommen ich guck mal da hin
dann geht die landschaft mit mehr dahin
dann kann ich mich so im kreis drehen
und wenn ich dann quasi die ganze zeit
so dahinter hingucker und ich mich so
drehe dann kann ich quasi bestimmen wie
sich die landschaft dort hinten
verändert also ein individueller shader
wo ich selbst sagen kann ohne drogen
zurückgedrückt euch mal so hin erinnert
mich ein bisschen an inception also das
ist sehr sehr krank das ist halt dieser
shader wenn ich das jetzt mal so im
kreis trier dass ich die welt sich quasi
mit mir dreht anime nach extrem gc
zurück
ich darf schon hinten brennt was aber
das ist einfach nur alt ist so krank
dass es so ihre dieser shader der ist so
heftig kraska also ich weiß nicht es
ruckelt alles ein bisschen damit aber
wir müssen halt bedenken er muss die
ganze welt quasi auf den kopf stellen es
müssen vielmehr chance geladen werden
dadurch also das ist schon sehr sehr
gern man kann die quasi selbst bestimmen
dreht euch mal die richtung dreht euch
mal so hin drückt euch mal dauert bis
juni o freunde jetzt kommt mal hier in
die kuhle landschaft auch mein alter das
ist so krank
das ist so krass geil das ist guckt euch
das mal an
also ich weiss nicht könnte mir den
ganzen tag spaß haben dauert linke es in
der beschreibung freuen wenn es euch
gefallen hat und ihr mehr top fünf
sachen wollte und eventuell auch
schreibt mir doch mal von was ihr eine
top 5 reihenfolge haben wollte weil
mittlerweile alles durch eventuell
möchte noch mal mit so richtigen
schildern
das war top 5 creepy shader die so ein
bisschen ihr seht schon also das sind ja
nicht schilder mit denen man
normalerweise spielt top-5 skins
irgendwie sowas schreibt in die
kommentare
wenn ihr jetzt noch dran seid und das
video bis zu ende geschaut hat schreibt
alle in die kommentare hashtag villiger
weil das hat ihre heftig bürger erste
hälfte billiger das seid ihr meine wilde
jabbar die sonne wird sagen wir ja bald
ist es euch gefallen hat dann zeigt es
mir mit einem mag ich und dann sehen wir
uns im nächsten video wieder
wahrscheinlich morgen